everybody what's going on it's Henry Lau
here I'm with BuzzFeed and I have a
movie coming out May 17th called the
dogs journey make sure you go watch it
I'm in it great movie and I'll be
talking about my first well I'm nervous
what do you guys like talk about some
you know stuff can really answer the
first time you realized you wanted to
pursue acting the first opportunity to
act was actually a film with Michelle
Yeoh called a final recipe where I I
played that played out genius chef at
that time I I never acted before I went
into it I met the dark there's a hey I
never acted and never did anything
before and she's like you're perfect for
the role and I was like what do you mean
then then I started to learn a little
bit more about acting and everything and
it was just it felt natural in a way not
easy but but but natural and I was like
wow I think maybe I could make this into
a career and and Here I am the first
celebrity you met about eight nine years
ago I was I was basically just just
starting my career I got into this
building I got into the elevator and
then I was just you know just going up
next thing you know it's somebody walks
in and ended up being Pierce Brosnan I'm
like well I know whoa that's
double-oh-seven
and then I was trying to keep my cool
and anything and he said hi to me and I
was like I was trying to I was trying to
be cool and everything I was like hey
but I was freaking out inside but yeah
that was a pretty a pretty crazy
experience first song you wrote oh I've
written some bad songs first songs I
wrote we're probably like you know when
you first learned to use the program and
you're just like dude dude dude into
tutus and tutus the first one I actually
kind of released it was called sick a
love and that was when I was it I was a
straight out of high school I don't even
know why I was sick of love back then
there's videos on the internet you guys
who check it out it's like going down
memory lane first thing you do when you
get home after a long day of work it
depends how long the day was I just a
lot of times I just just go straight to
the bed I don't even take off my clothes
I'm just I made it yeah I know I know
go to bed I just kind of died there oh I
do this every time after after a long
day work I carry around a ball all the
time
it's a massage ball and just put it
against the wall you guys know what I'm
talking about them and then I just I
kind of massage myself and then I go to
the bed so it all ends up in the back
yeah
first pet my first pet was actually a
bird bird's name was birdy I actually
really wanted a dog but my parents
didn't let me have a dog but this bird
was was was a really special bird my
bird would fly over to me come you know
lay right on my shoulder and there's
videos of me playing guitar and the
birds like right right on my shoulder
the first CD you ever bought I've never
told anybody this but it was actually a
a blink-182 CD cuz in high school I was
a I was a drummer Travis he was an
amazing drummer and I just remember
watching you know his videos and I would
he was like my my like high school idol
first celebrity crush
stop right now thank you very much I
need somebody with the Henry - uh-oh
when Christina Aguilera first came out I
was like wow she's beautiful and she's
she's an amazing amazing singer the
first time someone recognized you in
public
ah there's this there's this crazy
creative situation um a lot of people
got to know me through through Korean TV
the one of the the more early shows I
did was this show where we went to the
army
yeah it was called real man and it was
just documenting like you know just
normal people go in the army and that's
like kind of like you know going through
hard times and everything and everyone
kind of got to know me through that one
thing everyone kind of found out about
me was that my my nostrils are
heart-shaped I'm not I'm not kidding you
their their heart shape and I was on the
street and someone's like oh that's the
guy from the show and then I thought you
know the person will come up to me be
like hey can I get your signature or oh
could I get a picture with you and
they're like hey can I see you nostrils
and I was like for real but then you
know I was like happy that you know
anybody even knew me you know so I was
like yeah yeah I was really excited yeah
let me show you can take a picture of
you and your nostrils and I'm like okay
and then but if it was pretty cool do
you want to don't see the nostrils yeah
this is like normal nostrils and then I
can make them into like bigger hearts
like this 1 2 3
so small heart and if I like really love
someone or something I'll give them to
big heart
yeah and if I really love that can give
them like a like a flickering heart
[Music]